[Music]
new numbers just uncovered by the i-team
show more coveted cases than we
initially thought at the post office now
this is a story we've been following for
weeks
now we know just how many employees are
affected it is a story you will only see
on eight news now
the i-team's david charns is live
outside the post office's central
processing facility over on sunset
with what he found david
and brian we just confirmed that there
is a covit case over at the henderson
post office a first there we're outside
the facility where your mail is sorted
before it gets to you
and we found with dozens of cases more
employees are getting sick here
than anywhere else data obtained
by the i-team reveals more than 143
cases of coven 19
at postal facilities across the valley
115
cases confirmed with 28 other cases
listed
as unconfirmed the public records
request breaks down
outbreaks across the system with at
least 48 cases reported
at the central processing facility on
sunset
there have been at least 16 more inside
the administrative offices at the same
location at least
22 mail carriers have gotten sick with
clusters reported at at least
14 post offices from east las vegas to
spring valley to summerlin
since our first report about an 18
percent coveted outbreak at the sunset
center several employees have contacted
the i-team
expressing concern about the spread none
wanted to talk on camera for fear of
losing their job
postmaster general lewis dejoy briefly
spoke about employees calling out sick
during an august senate here senator our
employees are going
uh experiencing the covert uh pandemic
also and we have a significant uh
uh significant issue in employee
availability in many many parts of the
country that are also leading to
delays and delivery in that de joy told
congress a task force is keeping track
of those outbreaks
but our request was forwarded to the
department of labor which investigates
federal facilities
when you come into a lobby you'll see
that we're limiting the number of
customers in the facility
postal service officials declined an
interview instead
sharing these videos about required mask
wearing and social distancing both
inside their buildings and when your
mail is delivered
and employees are required to wear masks
when they're working with the public but
it's unclear if they're wearing them
behind the scenes we know that they're
required to do that because of the mass
mandate that the governor put into
effect
this summer but some of those employees
we talked to off camera say that that's
not what they're seeing
also important to point out that the
first covet case here
the same day the governor implemented
that policy
we're live at sunset in paradise i'm
david charns 8 news now